there's an old saying in media if you
don't have something nice to say you'll
do great
luckily the press has Trump so they
never have anything nice to say
eventually this starts to become a
problem since Trump got elected doctors
are seeing patients suffering from Trump
anxiety disorder or tad the symptoms of
tad feeling like the world is ending
I wonder why Donald Trump and his
erratic behavior could be leading the
United States towards World War 3
violating millions of people if this
border wall happens it will be an
unprecedented environmental catastrophe
we can't begin to normalize this this is
dangerous this is childish this is
unpresidential this is it's the end of
the presidential race
and it feels like the end of the world
[Applause]
never gets old but that's why you really
can't mock the ill when there's a whole
industry selling them this kind of
terror as their go-to evil the media has
replaced climate change with Trump
change everything bad in this world is
now due to Trump even as life improves
we've never been in a better spot with
North Korea GDP is going up unemployment
keeps shrinking optimism is higher than
Willie Nelson yet if you listen to the
other guys the sky isn't just falling
it's already fallen and it can't get up
it needs Life Alert but as much as the
chicken littles hate Trump where would
they be without him Trump's election
created a need that we didn't know we
had the media has never been louder
celebrities have never been shouting
academia has never been more strident so
haters imagine if Trump were to
disappear how large a hole would there
be and the lives of CNN and Morning Joe
and Chelsea Handler you think these
people suffer from Trump anxiety wait
till you see Trump withdrawal I wasted
everyone's time
everyone's everything and they feel bad
you don't think I feel bad I know that
you can't go back after Donald he's
added something to politics that we
haven't seen which is speed
not the drug the energy it's the first
time in eight years so many in the media
are sweating anxiety isn't from the
apocalypse it's from trying to keep up
all right let's introduce we have a new
face here as a guest Emily welcome to
the show I know you've been on Jesse's
program but other quality shows like
mine but I just thought maybe you'd say
tell us a little bit about yourself yeah
thank you so first of all thank you for
having me here today it really it's I'm
really excited to be here so thank you
for that and a little bit about myself
I'm a twelfth year attorney and I still
practice I'm licensed in California and
Washington but the majority of my career
was spent with the federal government
and criminal law as well and I had the
additional pleasure of cheering in the
NFL while I was an attorney for the
Oakland Raiders and I went on a USO tour
throughout Kuwait and Iraq visiting
troops
oh cool that really does remain to this
day my greatest honor there's me and one
of the Blackhawks
we flew around in which is an awesome
way to travel and I drive oh that's my
that's my like he chased a squirrel
right after that picture by the way with
that hat on it was ridiculous this is my
car I Drive a 72 Mach one and Greg was
telling me about his car before the show
but I'm pretty sure my engine's bigger
than I think your engine is bigger
that's beautiful 72 right yes I did in
California in Seattle it's harder yeah
just say I don't get dude like do they
give you the stink eye when you drive
around in that Berkeley I got more you
know negative looks yeah I think in
Seattle I just a beautiful car yeah you
just run over those Priuses yeah that's
what I would do what do you make of this
whole idea of anxiety could this be a
massive class action lawsuit against
Trump well they could certainly try
white right we saw a big class-action
suit about caffeine and coffee in
California but I just feel like it's one
more thing where the reality is that
people want to be outraged or affected
rather than informed right the whole
thing is ridiculous and we're seeing now
that this to me also is another over
Simplot oversimplification of the matter
oh I have this Trump anxiety syndrome
and so that must mean XY and Z well what
is that the Ruda right fear and fright
is usually from lack of education so if
we could talk about things more engaged
and
told manner people probably wouldn't be
so frightened of positive news coming
out of the administration you know want
to paraphrase a stoic if you are
offended you are complicit in the
outrage got that from a producer that
was yeah very good so it means it's like
Donald isn't really making you sick it's
you're letting him get you sick right
it's like you have to learn how to
manage the emotions and turn it into
something productive correct right
because I think Donald plays on emotions
every day I mean he plays he on the fear
factor he likes to stir up his base with
fear he likes to mock people and
intimidate people but here's the thing
you can even make fun of Trump
derangement syndrome right but I think
that look at it from the Democrats point
of view Greg that's it's the base is
anti Trump and energized to turnout in
the midterms and all the numbers right
now are flowing towards the Democrats
because the Democratic base is so
energized right they are upset about
Trump and arranged you say why things
are going so great hey people look
around they say you know what this
country is in a place I've never seen it
before I don't even recognize it in some
cases and they're outraged but that's a
cycle again a psychological problem
you can't just speak the truth well no
it's psychological not prayer I mean if
you look at the job numbers and the
economy those are real you know real
progress the sight you're talking about
the sight real serious psychological
problems people think something's wrong
when there's something good going on
look at the taxes oh geez
we're gonna give a tax cut to the
working men of America and it goes to
nobody but the rich and that's 600 each
year check whatever a feeling yeah I
think what happened is his Trump was
elected not to bring continuity and did
not you know guide the country along the
path that it was going Donald Trump was
elected to grab America by the back of
the neck and then yank it from off the
edge of the cliff for some people that's
very thrilling yeah for some people
that's incredibly jarring and I think
those people are mentally weak I mean we
had generations that storm the beaches
and now they're crying in the streets so
I think it's because the media is so
negative and the media is constantly
saying the sky is falling and people
can't process that it's also because
Trump
is constantly battling everybody he's
taking down institutions he's fighting
with people he's on Twitter and we've
never had a president like that before
him people can't process that and then
three people are frustrated because they
haven't been able to take him down
they've thrown everything at this guy
and he's still at 45 to 46 percent and
for them that's incredibly frustrating
and they need to see a shrink you know
DNA let's say you are the shrink and I
come in and I go I have all this anxiety
over Donald Trump he's driving me crazy
what kind of advice would you give me
all right I would say it depends on are
you an action-oriented person or are you
somebody who needs to just turn off the
TV and turn off Twitter
I know people they're just like I don't
like to watch the news anymore it's too
negative or especially if it was violent
you know they don't want to they don't
want to watch that so you do have a
choice you know if in the Serenity
Prayer you ask for wisdom - for the
things that you cannot change and the
courage to know the difference or the
things that you can't and so I think
that the other thing is and I do think
the Democrats have done this a large
extent but so have Trump supporters
which is channel that energy into
something else run for office donate
decide to turn something into action so
that you can actually get involved if
you feel like you're more involved and
you're actually being able to do
something on either side then you can
deal with your anxiety better but more
is probably I think getting on Twitter
is probably good I do think that there's
something to what Jesse said Emily which
is like I think the stress actually is
real and it's not it's it has to do with
time compression the fact that because
Trump has packed like five incidents
into one day it's like usually a
politician would yeah something
controversial once a week but it seems
like he just it's like to him News's
shuffleboard like if there's a news item
he'll hit that one out with another news
item and then and so we are just
constantly racing and racing and I can
kind of see where that gets exhausting
even for us yeah well sure that the
rapidity of the media cycle can
certainly be exhausting but also I feel
like part of the issue is focusing on
the that fright and the fear of what
hasn't happened yet and we're ignoring
them to our detriment the negatives that
still are in place so you know we were
just talking about California well that
still has the highest poverty rate if
you take into account cost of living
and yet we have 125 approx billionaires
living in that state yeah
with 500 billion dollars plus among them
and then LA County just leveraged what
you know 430 million dollars worth of
debt to combat the homeless problem that
is growing by the day so it's almost a
shell game where we are focused on what
this media on the headlines the
oversimplification and then ignoring
what really needs our attention
I'm stealing those stats when I do
Tucker later one the median Hollywood
share some responsible for this I think
because they're the ones that are
keeping it at a doomsday level and
they're gonna fork out millions now a
lot of people in Hollywood are gonna
fork out millions in the midterms
obviously with the hope to win both
houses and impeach is that the realistic
goal you think no but I think they I
think realistically they have a shot at
the house if that's what you're asking
but you know I'm struck by this
conversation because to me you say it's
the Hollywood elite it's the media it's
everybody but Donald Trump but I'm
thinking if I'm anxious if the American
people are anxious and according to what
I saw in your I agree with you they are
more anxious apparently you can measure
this right and and they are more anxious
well what about Donald Trump's repeated
lies what about the idea stands next to
Putin like a submissive puppy and says
oh I believe Putin not the Americans I
mean wait a second what's tied is this
guy on I thought he was our president
well I don't know I think people are
more resilient on the right than people
on the left during the Obama
administration there was you know racial
riots there was a lot of domestic terror
attacks there were gas price spikes
there was premium spikes with the health
care situation there was a lot of
uncertainty and volatility during that
time conservative didn't rush to see a
shrink you know what they did they had a
drink and they went to work the next day
they created the Tea Party and they
translated that into votes and there was
Isis remember yes that was a little bit
of anxiety-producing yes you know
worried about the future of the world
the other thing I would say is a part of
this is that the celeb celebrities in
Hollywood have said they're going to be
more engaged now than ever right thing
is that the president yes for president
Trump he does better if he has someone
or something to work against so I
actually think if they if Hollywood
really wanted to help the Democrats if
we've better just to sit back write
checks and register new voters
than giving him something to run again
that's what Clooney Clooney said he
would know who wouldn't hang around
Obama because he didn't want to tarnish
Obama with the Hollywood you know stench
they just met behind closed doors
exactly